you and your family recently had an
estate sale which i think is awesome
because my sister just had a garage sale
so an estate sale
it's like a fancy yeah it's a fancy
garage sale my sister was like so
excited we love garage shells we didn't
ever venture to estate cells because we
didn't have the money if that were kids
were like but is that what it is it's
like a fancy garage sale i've never been
to it you know what it is it's like um
well i'm a massive collector of crap so
if you guys went online and saw what i
was saying there's a word for that
porter yes my sister says that the
difference between hoarding and
collecting are aisles
so i'm sort of more of a i'm going to be
trying somewhere in between that but um
well i want to show this is some of your
stuff so do you have a fascination with
creepy dolls
what is what is the creepy dolphin i
just need to know i think if there are
past lives i would have a few questions
for myself i don't
i mean yeah yeah
it's amazing but i actually would have
wanted that little number like the
tribal thing that's cool like hanging on
the brick wall that's cool yeah i mean
yeah well and and the surfboard no i
don't surf yeah i got that for when i
turned 40 and i'd like to learn to serve
so i'm going to sign i just turned 40
and i will not be learning how to serve
were you ever terrified of like sharks
or anything like no no and 40 was my
best year 40 is already
it's been days and it's already my best
year it's your best three days yeah it's
my best moment no it literally i i think
life gets exponentially the older you
get like because you get wiser hopefully
some of us don't yeah but um but you get
to be my age you're going to be really
wise no it's like
no i do i feel like life does get better
it gets simpler and you realize like no
isn't a crappy thing to say to someone
it's actually just setting a boundary
it's nice i've been to therapy
because it took me getting breast cancer
to learn okay sometimes you have to say
no as an exercise yeah you cannot make
everybody happy you can't uh say yes to
everything what is it with artists why
do we we're people please it's like and
women yeah oh yeah yeah
[Music]
you